ils ont installé 298 chaises pour les
281 18 passagers disparus du vol m h 17
les familles des victimes l'ont fait
devant l'ambassade de la russie à la
haye pour dénoncer l'indifférence du
kremlin diplôme ils nous regardent
derrière les rideaux mais n'osent même
pas nous parler d'eux des chaises vides
sont consacrés à bryce fredricks et sa
copine daisy il avait la vie devant eux
et s'envolait pourquoi la longue pour le
17 juillet 2014 leur chambre est intacte
salines la mère de bryce n'oserait
touché dès ce soir
peut-être que le procès l'aidera à
surmonter son deuil
elle espère qu'il exposera tout au moins
les années de mensonges du kremlin
mais dans leur course aux quarts la
russie ni à ce jour toute responsabilité
dans le destin tragique du vol match 17
quelques l'enquêté conclut que c'est un
missile boc provenant d'une base
militaire russe qui a battu l'avion du
lucre est la solution est pourtant un
clip mais nous y pensons mais comme on
s'y attendait le box des accusés était
ville ce matin pour l'ouverture
officielle du procès moscou refuse
d'extrader les quatre hommes soupçonnés
d'être responsables
tous ont des hauts gradés des forces
séparatistes pro russes qui auraient
selon la preuve transporter des missiles
et camoufler la preuve ils seront jugés
par contumace pour le meurtre des 298 de
passagers exposé mail enquête se
poursuit il nous voulons mettre à jour
toute la chaîne de commandement de ceux
qui ont tiré deux missiles à ceux qui en
ont donné l'ordre a expliqué l'enquêteur
indique rag il est entré au tribunal
entouré des familles venues de partout
pour assister aux procédures
il y avait un seul canadien à bord andré
engel un étudiant en médecine
sa famille n'y sera pas car c'est trop
douloureux le procès m h 17 s'ouvrent
deux mois à peine après l'explosion du
vol 750 de la compagnie ukrainienne à
rhein abattu par erreur par du missile
iranien en décollant terre 50 canadiens
ont péri dans l'accident
le tout membre a sauvé korian sato et
charlotte sont les défenseurs des cartes
nos six ans plus tard céline elle attend
toujours de connaître la vérité elle
espère surtout entendre des excuses pour
enfin panser ses plaies
ici tamara altérait secoue radio-canada
moscou